Rome's Caracalla baths epitomized the
wealth of the ancient Roman Empire bill
to welcome up to eight thousand people a
day the ruins of the vast structure are
one of the eternal cities top tourist
attractions but now the site's vast
underground tunnel system is also open
to the public
our very own Seth Doane got a look at
the miles of Roman history being
explored for the first time in centuries
nearly two thousand years ago it was
built to impress and still does today
even in ruins the elaborate mosaics in
soaring multi-story structures were the
public baths or tatter may of Roman
Emperor Caracalla it was a massive spa
of the ancient world
complete with gyms saunas libraries and
three main pools when cold one tepid one
hot and now as of late June there's a
new world to explore underground if you
go upstairs you can see the great beauty
of the baths and of Rome of course if
you are here you understand the impact
on the technology in the greatness of
the Roman architects Marina Peter amante
has been director here for more than two
decades so I was alone for many many
years in this area and thinking and
desiring to open these tunnels to the
public this is the first time the public
has ever been allowed into this part of
this sprawling network of underground
tunnels
so far they've excavated about a mile of
them but still have around two and a
half miles to go
in the tunnels they projected video
artwork dreamed up by a contemporary
artist as a way to evoke feelings and
help visitors understand the past down
here was where the work happened with
slaves moving wood and lighting fires to
heat the pool and saunas above for the
up to eight thousand daily guests I
think that the technology inside the
baths of caracalla is very very
complicated and very rare francesco
prosperity is the superintendent of
archeology in rome no small job he's
taken us deep into the once forgotten
Domus Aurea Emperor Nero's Palace where
they introduced virtual reality to help
recreate the past then after Rome subway
excavation turned up so many artifacts
he turned a metro station into a museum
and now this people think of the
Colosseum the Circus Maximus people
don't know as much the baths of
caracalla
you're a writer and this is strange
because Caracalla is the biggest
monument in the ancient rome if you take
the Colosseum and put it inside
Caracalla the ancient baths were free to
the public
showcasing the generosity of the Emperor
and the grandeur of the empire Daniel
Schmitt came from Virginia to see the
history of them carting the wood to be
able to heat the water in order to keep
the people clean and besides his
nine-year-old marveled at something else
like take it back
these cavernous tunnels now filled with
art were first excavated in the 1930s in
part to stabilize another structure
above a giant stage each summer Rome's
opera moves outside here mixing art Ben
archeology above-ground - with the
Caracalla baths providing a magnificent
backdrop millennium in the making CBS
this morning Saturday Seth Doane Rome